when i think about script writing it
really is
intertwined with directing for me i i
and editing too i really do
experience the whole process as one
stories come
when ideas come it can happen
in all ways where
how a story unfolds sometimes i'll have
a character idea for
and and i'm looking for a story to put
the character
other times i've had more an idea of
of story or of place or or a visual
and uh and that helps me discover the
character
but every movie is different that way
movie making is a combination of both
sort of practical decisions
and storytelling decisions like you know
what would be the kind of furniture you
would just find in a place like this if
it was a pre-furnished apartment in our
minds
for the same reason i often use real
names in my scripts of
people i know because it's immediately a
real
person to me i believe it well like i
know that
i know who roger greenberg is because i
grew up with roger greenberg i had
deep affection for him and for that time
in my life and even though the movie had
no
literal connection to that calling him
roger greenberg
made me love him and and and also it
made it real to me
[Music]
i i do take things from uh
ideas come from i should say from my own
life um
philip roth has a quote about
his own writing that he that he would
take two stones of reality
and rub them together to spark the
imagination and
and i find that that's not that i i
don't work dissimilarly
like i said sort of
an interaction i have or an experience
in my life where i will
uh write down a piece of it or something
or a detail or
and that might find its way into a story
at some point but
i find that i'm not able to truly start
writing a screenplay until
it's a fiction i i don't i i
you know my movies aren't
autobiographical um
uh but they are personal yeah and yeah
and what's interesting about blue velvet
is it's
it's very specific when it's very
generalized at the same time lumberton
or lumber you know where is that you
know i mean but it seems
we all know where it is but we have no
idea where it is um which is amazing um
yeah place is a big part of it and i
um and i'd like to know the place when
i'm writing
um i mean obviously i need to know the
place but i mean i like to even have
visual
ideas of the streets the the the
locations if i can
um when i'm writing uh because it
i feel like it grounds me it's for the
same reason i often use real names
in my scripts of people i know um
not because i'm writing about them at
all i would never do that but
but um because it's immediately a real
person to me i believe it well like i
know that
i know who roger greenberg is because i
grew up with roger greenberg
he wasn't roger greenberg and greenberg
but he
um because like also because i hadn't
seen him since i was like 15
but but um but i had
deep affection for him and for that time
in my life and even though the movie had
no
literal connection to that calling him
roger greenberg
made me love him and and and also it
made it real to me
it took a long time to find this
apartment because i had definite ideas
of what it
should be one thing that was very
important to me was having this
line here in the middle of the space
that way when he's here
talking and she's you know standing over
here
you have two people who can't see each
other talking to each other but we can
see both of them
and it just seemed like so much in the
movie at this point is this together and
separate
thing that's going on between them and
and this could
illustrate that could you change it so i
could take him
um it's just one night he's looking
forward to it
movie making is a combination of both
sort of practical decisions
and storytelling decisions like you know
what would be the kind of furniture you
would just find in a place like this if
it was it was a pre-furnished apartment
in our mine i'll take a juice box
the juice box initially came from the
fact of i thought well okay well
charlie's living here alone he doesn't
have much
but what came from that is of course is
that then she has the juice box
and she ends up making her way over to
this chair here
and and laying it down on the floor this
all leads to the final
shot of the scene which is this wide
shot as he falls to the ground
and i felt like the juice boxes henry's
presence
in their lives and in our lives as an
audience you know that he's not in the
scene he's not here but
but he is there and he's really
powerless in this situation
i don't outline or beat it out in any
kind of
obvious way but i i um i i
i kind of find often i'm collecting
things and
and often i start in notebooks writing
ideas and
sometimes it's i mean it's the same idea
rewritten
i keep thinking it's a new idea and i
keep writing it down and realizing that
it's a
it's a little like jack nicholson in the
shining i'm just repeating
the same thing over and over um uh
and but i find in some ways it's like
i'm working
through it and and and or i guess
i am and so it's
at a certain point something starts to
activate and then i
feel like i'm ready to write or you know
to write it and and um uh
and then i'll move it to the computer
because it always looks more official
when it's typed
you know and uh um
uh and then usually it's sort of
transcribing the notes in a way and
then opening them up into scenes and
um the but this can
go on for quite some time and i and i
and and there there are ones that are
that don't go anywhere don't go anywhere
right away um
uh uh usually although this is not true
at the moment
usually when i'm finishing a movie
like when i was finishing the meyerwood
stories the the editing of it
i started this one started to find
like to it's almost like color starts
entering a the picture or something and
and i started to kind of see it and have
ideas about it that's when i approached
the actors that's when i
i really started writing at nernus and
then it the the writing then
i mean i don't know maybe six months or
something but it's it it feels
relatively
directed and faster then but it's also
years
and getting to that point um and there
are aspects of this movie that i
have thought about for a long time and
not uh
you know that that i haven't uh known
how
you know how to put them in you know how
what what the movie was
or where they fit in the movie welcome
to santa barbara noah
thanks for having me um this film
when i've seen it a couple of times now
um
it plays at times like a thriller it
plays at other times like a legal
uh drama there is romance
and screwable comedy moments
and we have musical numbers it's when
you were writing
is that something that you were aware
that
the shifting of uh genres
i i i i became
aware of it i wasn't aware of i didn't
start writing it thinking i would have
those opportunities but
the i did find as i was working on it in
the material that there were all these
as you're saying kind of embedded genres
in it and
it was partly my job to
kind of be open to them and not
uh and not be afraid of it and and it
was something that in shooting it we
thought about too
in terms of how we wanted to shoot the
movie that
we could you know that
you know that certain scenes could have
kind of screwball elements to them
people going in and out of doors you
know when they're
she's gonna serve him the papers
that is like on one hand a kind of like
comic
it was like an opportunity for a kind of
comic set piece
uh but knowing at the same time that
that envelope is
also like a bomb under a table that the
protagonist
you know or one of our protagonists
doesn't know about
and the audience does and that creates
anxiety
i mean that that's like a great thriller
set up as well so
those kinds of um
those opportunities have you know sort
of afforded themselves to me
as i was i was working on it
uh but it actually i i
i think a lot about there's a lot of how
i
you know i went through a period after i
made i made two movies when i was quite
young i made kicking and screaming
when i was 24 25 and then movie mr
jealousy when i was 27
and then i didn't make another movie
till i was
34 or something 34 35 was squid in the
whale
and that period for me was a period of
real
struggle and in my sort of
conscious mind i was
i was just trying to get another movie
made i was writing things trying to get
another movie made what i was
doing unconsciously uh
was growing up and
and i felt very much like i mean francis
talks at some point someone says what do
you do and she goes well it's hard to
describe and they say why she's because
i don't really do it
and i felt that way i made two movies
but i didn't feel like i could call
myself a filmmaker
because i wasn't doing it and i wanted
to do it again but i wasn't doing it
and it was a it was a very hard time and
i
i emotionally reflected a lot
on that time from from my point of view
i mean so much of greta's in the movie
too obviously
um but um uh you know in in that sort of
you know what what i guess they call
quarter life
uh uh crisis that's when
stories come when ideas come it can
happen
in all ways uh where
how a story unfolds sometimes i'll have
a character idea for
and and i'm looking for a story to put
the character
uh movie i made greenberg that ben
stiller played i i had this sort of
notion of the character
but not the story um other times i've
had
more an idea of of of story or of place
or or a visual and uh
and that helps me discover the character
uh
but every movie is different that way
and and these are all
you know i have notebooks and things
that i'll keep
notes over time and uh and
sometimes it can feel like two very
disparate ideas
like like i said like a location and a
character
again in the case of greenberg los
angeles and that character seemed to
somehow
intersect in a way that that gave me
ideas and gave me story
the process is cinematographer robbie
ryan and i by the time we're rehearsing
in here we've now shot listed the movie
probably twice
but then the actors are going to feel
their way through this idea
and sometimes there's choreography that
i have that they'll just say yeah no it
makes sense
and then other times actually i don't
think i should stand yet or i'd like to
stand earlier or
i don't know that i would come out on
that line and then
we all kind of get into it together i
think about being married to you and
that woman is a stranger to me
when we do the close-ups after we've
been somewhat wider for most of the
scene and we go in we have some three
versions of the clothes
but it's like here then it's gonna hear
and then it really is
you know in in here and there's a
sequence in the last picture show that
jeff bridges and timothy bottoms are
circling a car
and they start to have this argument and
he gets in closer but
he starts cutting back and forth within
the same line so it gets
really kinetic and it felt the scene
wanted that for this sequence in
particular because it almost
becomes them just hurling insults at
each other and it's like the train
can't stop and we're just going in but
again had to be very
particularly staged and
architected because we we knew what
words we were going to cut on
and so i would have them do particular
gestures on each
line so it wasn't just the word it was
also the movement
so he would move his head you know back
to being a hack and he would lean in and
so
it's almost like that they're like being
thrilled at each other
editorially i can't believe i have to
know you
forever oh you're freaking insane
this waltz was something we spent a lot
of time figuring out and this really
came out of all the rehearsals and the
blocking which was
exactly how high is the hole when he's
going to hit it
we shot it repeatedly so he always had
to hit the same spot
well i think i mean for for artists i
think it's
it's a hard time to work you know
because everywhere so distracted and
um and i think um but i also think it's
so
important that we do and and it's i mean
both for our own
mental health it's helpful because it
takes you out of
the moment momentarily takes you out of
the moment
um wizard barking in the back
and then um uh you know but yeah i would
say
to to to to keep working and
and uh you know from an artist's
perspective to to work as much as
possible
um uh because i think
it both for self-sanity and also we're
going to need the
we're going to need the the the art that
comes out of this moment is going to be
really important
when i think about script writing it
really is
intertwined with directing for me i i i
and editing too i really do
experience the whole process as one and
i don't
um and um and and i want to talk about
screenwriting but i i'm
but i do i i
i do find a script that's
that isn't a movie um
of my own uh somewhat useless
like i don't think i don't find i don't
i don't think scripts
maybe some are somewhere but i don't
think they're
complete things they're by nature
potential and and uh and
you know they've been called blueprints
or you know um
uh and some directors use them very much
as just guides that you know robert
altman you know
kind of make an entirely new movie out
of the script he was given
i follow my scripts uh quite closely
i'm interpreting them as a director but
i'm i'm following we
the the lines are the the lines and and
um uh the scenes of the scenes
but even so on their own
i don't um
i don't get a lot of delight out of them
i guess i should say but but i
um the way i work is
and i edit the way i pretty much the way
i write which is
um often i now anyway
i sit down to write when i kind of feel
like i have enough
to start and i'm take a lot of notes and
always and and
often there's a few different things
that are
sort of going on at once and one thing
kind of announces itself
and that when that wire kind of like
electricity
goes through that wire i i try to follow
it
but once i have a like scenes or a
beginning or something i tend to
i tend to work forward and go back and
revise and then go a little bit
further and then go back and revise so
by the time i'm
done with the script it's close
to being ready which is the same way i i
don't have a rough cut i
i start at the beginning with my editor
jen lame
and we we cut the movie
we go a little bit and then we go back
and we revise same thing
so that when we're done uh it doesn't
mean we of course we make changes
throughout but and once you see it all
together it gives you other ideas but
the um but it's generally in very good
shape i i don't i don't
sort of throw it up there roughly and
then
uh that i find too disheartening i think
you